denk mal kurz darüber nach welche großen
missionen der esa fallen euch jetzt so
auf anhieb ein beinahe roskosmos und in
letzter zeit auch der chinesischen
raumfahrt agentur ist das irgendwie
einfacher da hätten wir natürlich dem
ersten menschen auf dem mond dem ersten
menschen im weltall oder eine eigene
nationale raumstation und hier in europa
das ist ja schon irgendwie ein bisschen
seltsam wenn was forschung und
wirtschaftskraft angeht sind wir in
europa eigentlich top aufgestellt und
selbst ich habe ein handy hülle von der
nasa aber nicht von der esa warum es so
wirkt als würde die esa so weit
zurückgegangen was der neue
generaldirektor dagegen tun will und wer
verhindert hat dass schon der alte
generaldirektor etwas ändern konnte
genau darum geht es heute drei doktor
watson
[Musik]
natürlich muss ich die europäische
raumfahrtagentur den sich ändernden
bedingungen anpassen damit europa sich
bewusst wird will europa macht die welt
radprofis zu bestätigen was in die
brüche geht und wie kann man das
erreicht
dieses video hier wurde durch unsere
vielen supporter auf petri unmöglich
gemacht wie ihr vielleicht wisst sind
wie ein unabhängiges team aus inzwischen
zehn leuten die alle unter anderem an
doktor watson arbeiten und natürlich
auch ein gehalt bekommen wollen wir
gehören nicht zu funk meint du mir
wirklich nicht obwohl das immer wieder
geschrieben wird hinter uns steht auch
kein großer konzern wir sind wirklich
unabhängig und nur dieses team an zehn
leuten und wir finanzieren uns über
werbung und kooperationen mit
auftraggebern und genau deswegen sind
wir so unglaublich dankbar für jede
unterstützung auf pagewizz denn je mehr
support wird da bekommen desto
unabhängiger sind wir von werbung und
desto mehr und coolere videos können wir
für euch machen deswegen ein riesiger
shoutout an euch katrins danke für euren
support und wenn du uns jetzt
unterstützen möchtest dann kannst du das
sehr gerne unter twitter.com / doktor
watson tun was inzwischen übrigens auch
über paypal gibt man braucht nicht mehr
unbedingt eine kreditkarte ok jetzt
zurück zum video bevor wir verstehen
können was gerade bei der esa abgeht
müssen wir erst einmal ein paar basics
etablieren die european space agency ist
ein unabhängiger zusammenschluss von
insgesamt 22 mitgliedstaaten und ein
ministerium der eu wie viele glauben zu
den mitgliedsländern zählen nämlich auch
großbritannien die schweiz und norwegen
die ja alle nicht in der eu sind
mittlerweile hat die esa neben ihrem
hauptquartier in paris zentren in
darmstadt hier in köln italien
großbritannien spanien den niederlanden
und belgien
in diesen esa zentren werden unter
anderem astronautinnen und astronauten
ausgebildet
es wird in die satellitenkommunikation
überwacht und der weltraum wird
beobachtet mit der ariane und der vega
hat die esa außerdem zwei raketen mit
denen kommerzielle starts von satelliten
durchgeführt werden können die staaten
vom weltraumbahnhof in
französisch-guayana aus zu den greatest
hits der esa gehören galileo das erste
zivile satelliten navigations und
ortungssystem kopernikus eines der
umfangreichsten satelliten programme zur
erkundung und überwachung unserer erde
oder auch die sonde solar orbiter dies
übrigens gerade auf dem weg zur sonne um
dort so nabel dazu machen wie kein
raumschiff jemals vorjahr
bisher hatte er sah noch keine
möglichkeit selbstständig astronautinnen
und astronauten ins all zu bringen am 23
april diesen jahres ist mit thoma pesci
aber immerhin der erste europäer mit
einer crew dragon -kapsel von spacex zur
iss geflogen auch der start der sechsten
generation der ariane war eigentlich
bereits für 2020 geplant und wird jetzt
voraussichtlich erst 2022 stattfinden
aber dass sich gesteckte deadlines
verschieben das scheint ja in der
raumfahrt nicht unmöglich zu sein
ein vergleich des budgets von nasa und
esa für das jahr 2021 zeigt aber dann
doch wie deutlich der abstand zur
konkurrenz aus amerika rein finanziell
ist während die esa auf knapp 6 5
milliarden euro zurückgreifen kann liegt
das budget der nasa umgerechnet etwa 21
milliarden euro ist also mehr als
dreimal so hoch ok halten wir das
erstmal so fest die esa scheint mit
ihren missionen durchaus im spiel der
großen weltraum nationen mitzumischen
trotzdem ist man finanziell noch lange
nicht auf einer ebene mit zb der nasa
und man braucht noch unterstützung um
astronauten nach da oben zu bringen das
ist halt auch immer noch eine geldfrage
und jetzt mal ganz blöd gefragt sind
emissionen deswegen so uninteressant
dass niemand darüber berichtet ich meine
zugegebenermaßen dann müssen wir uns
jetzt erst mal an die eigene nase fassen
wie hier bei doktor watson berichten
vielmehr über die nasa und auch spacex
also eine einzelne firma als wird die
gesamte esa wir geloben aber mit diesem
video hier besserung aber einen grund
für die geringere aufmerksamkeit könnten
ja auch kooperationen mit anderen
raumfahrtagenturen sein oder naja also
in der raumfahrt
bietet sich an zusammenzuarbeiten die
esa selbst sich da schon ein gutes
beispiel dafür was viele dieser
missionen könnten die einzelnen
mitgliedsländer für sich gar nicht auf
die waage bringt deshalb empfiehlt es
hier auf europäischer ebene
zusammenzuarbeiten und viele dieser
projekte davor da natürlich auch
internationale zusammenarbeit um mal
einen blick auf die philosophie der
europäischen raumfahrtagentur zu werfen
haben wir bei der esa selbst nachgefragt
und konnten mit keinem geringeren
sprechen als thomas reiter er war
astronaut und der erste deutsche der im
all einen weltraumspaziergang
unternommen hat heute ist er bei der esa
koordinator für internationale agenturen
und sogar berater des generaldirektors
damals wurde uns die aufgabe gegeben
dass wir die zusammenarbeit der
europäischen staaten
in der weltraumforschung für
ausschließlich friedliche zwecke
voranbringen
weltraumtechnologien
entwickeln die anwendung in hinblick auf
deren nutzung hier auf der erde
entsprechend entwickeln und genau das
haben wir in den über 50 jahren glaube
ich ganz gut hinbekommen
zusammenarbeiten liegt also
gewissermaßen in der dna der esa das
klingt ja erstmal nach einer guten sache
und wie man zb an der iss sehen kann
sind auch schon ziemlich große erfolge
bei herumgekommen das könnte aber auch
dazu führen dass man weniger von der esa
hört bei so einer zusammenarbeit muss
man sich den credit ja teilen und steht
nicht alleine auf der titelseite
außerdem könnte man sich die frage
stellen ob bei den ganzen kooperationen
nicht auch die konkurrenz verloren geht
angeblich belebt konkurrenz das geschäft
oder ja diese konkurrenz die gibt es
definitiv
insbesondere in einer zeit in der sich
diese sogenannte new space economy
entwickelt gibt es natürlich gerade was
die kommerziellen aspekte der raumfahrt
betrifft eine steigende konkurrenz aber
eben auch im wissenschaftlichen bereich
[Musik]
der begriff news pace ist im grunde gar
nicht mehr so neu er beschreibt
geschäftsmodelle die die raumfahrt mit
der digitalen wirtschaft verbinden teile
der new space bewegung sind auch die
kommerzielle und die private raumfahrt
wird gerne natürlich spacex als
positives beispiel hervorgehoben und das
auch völlig zu recht wie die
kommerzialisierung und space ex die
raumfahrt in den letzten jahren bereits
verändert haben das könnt ihr euch
übrigens in diesem video hier von uns
ansehen aber auch spacex hat sich nicht
einfach dazu entschieden raketen zu
bauen war dann damit erfolgreich und
macht ihnen maske jetzt damit die
taschen voll wenn tatsächlich wäre es
2008 ohne einen sehr lukrativen auftrag
der nasa aus gewesen mit dem traum einer
maßstab und auch hier in europa würde
ohne die hilfe der esa wahrscheinlich
nicht viel gehen das haben sie aber zum
glück auch selbst erkannt dass die
kommerzielle entwicklung angeht da
glaube ich sind wir sehr daran
interessiert dass in europa noch stärker
voran zu bringen wenn wir also gerade
nach usa schauen wo in den vergangenen
jahren oder im vergangenen jahrzehnt da
eine enorme entwicklung stattgefunden
hat dann kann man unschwer erkennen dass
diese fähigkeit daten aus dem weltraum
zu erhalten zu verarbeiten und dann
daraus irgendwelche diensten zu
entwickeln unsere zukünftige entwicklung
ganz massiv beeinflussen werden man kann
sagen das
hochtechnisierte
volkswirtschaften sehr stark von solchen
diensten abhängen und daraus ergibt sich
natürlich auch die notwendigkeit dass
wir uns aus europäischer sicht auf diese
situation einstellen dass wir
entsprechend unsere fähigkeiten unserer
industrie in diesem bereich fördern und
der mann der die esa nun auf diesen
neuen kurs ausrichten soll ist josef
aschbacher erst seit dem ersten märz
2021 der neue generaldirektor der eso
und durchaus ambitioniert in seinen
neuen job gestartet denn er hat die
agenda 2025 vorgestellt darin setzt er
fünf prioritäten die die esa seiner
meinung nach in der zukunft angehen muss
und das sind eine bessere zusammenarbeit
zwischen der esa und der eu die
förderung der kommerziellen raumfahrt
die absicherung gegen gefahren aus dem
all die optimierung von emissionen und
die interne transformation der esa wer
sich das alles im detail ansehen möchte
der kann sich die agenda gerne unter
dieser quelle hier in der video
beschreibung mal durchlesen ich fand es
sehr spannend und aufschlussreich
aschbacher spricht in seiner agenda
davon dass europa auch im bereich der
privaten raumfahrt noch deutlich hinter
den usa zurück liegt während in
washington 2009 10 umgerechnet rund 5
milliarden euro für private förderungen
locker gemacht wurden waren es in europa
gerade mal 100 88 millionen die man in
startups investiert hat und ähnlich wie
in amerika kennt wohl bald auch in asien
viel investiert werden da wird europa da
mithalten kann nennt er drei zentrale
punkte talent zugang zu kapital und
schnellere innovation es klingt jetzt
erstmal nicht so besonders revolutionär
soll aber dazu führen dass zum beispiel
förderungen einfacher zu bekommen sind
auch die investitionen in
zukunftsweisende technologien sollen
erhöht und die bürokratischen hürden für
kleine startups reduziert werden die esa
soll den privaten markt in europa mit
hochziehen und will davon am ende durch
bessere technologie auch profitieren und
das finde ich mega cool aber um das
alles umzusetzen muss die esa anspacher
auch einen internen wandel durchmachen
und der beinhaltet den abbau von
bürokratie aber auch und ich finde es
spannend dass man das im jahr 2021 immer
noch betonen muss den ausbau digitaler
strukturen genauso wie die interne
kommunikation und die stärkung der
diversität in den teams der esa das
klingt jetzt so als würde josef
aschbacher die esa in den nächsten
jahren komplett umkrempeln aber nicht so
schnell einer der das bei seinem antritt
auch vorhatte war johann dietrich wörner
aschbach us vorgänger nachdem bekannt
wurde dass er seinen posten vorzeitig
abgeben wird ging er in einem interview
darauf ein dass seine großen pläne zu
beginn ziemlich schnell durchkreuzt
wurden hauptverantwortlich dafür waren
unter anderem die nationalen interessen
der verschiedenen mitgliedstaaten die
ihren einfluss nicht verlieren wollten
frankreich zum beispiel hatte maßgeblich
die finger mit im spiel als werner
dieses jahr seinen posten räumen muss
und aus frankreich kommen auch gerade
anscheinend schon wieder die ersten
bedenken an den plänen die esa als
investor für private
raumfahrtunternehmen auftreten zu lassen
zum beispiel vom chef von arianespace
das ist der hersteller der isar raketen
er macht sich sorgen dass startups die
aktuell an sogenannten micro london
arbeiten also einen kleinen raketen
später auch mal große raketen bauen und
damit konkurrenz für arianespace werden
könnten und hier deutet sich eines der
möglichen probleme an weshalb die esa
die möglichkeiten der kommerzialisierung
und privatisierung in der vergangenheit
etwas
verschlafen hat im vergleich zur nasa
die nur die interessen eines landes
vertritt gibt es bei der esa 22 nationen
die natürlich immer wieder einfluss
nehmen wollen das kann dann zu internen
machtkämpfen führen von denen am ende
niemand etwas hart außerdem scheint es
so als würde sich der ein oder andere in
der industrie auf seine mesa monopol
ausruhen und bloß keine konkurrenz neben
sich wollen aber wie thomas reiter schon
richtig erwähnt hat ohne konkurrenz gibt
es eben auch weniger anreize für
innovation und optimierung
ok wo stehen wir jetzt also mit der esa
ich hoffe dass der neue chef josef
bacher seine ziele tatsächlich
durchsetzen kann denn von einer
förderung der privaten raumfahrt würden
wir hier am ende alle profitieren weil
wir dann auch hier bei uns mehr
innovation und fortschritt sehen würden
auch hoffe ich dass die diversität
talent und bitte jetzt mal langsam
wirklich auch digitalisierung gefördert
wird und was bei all den anstehenden
veränderungen hoffentlich immer gleich
bleibt ist das ziel mit der
weltraumforschung das leben von uns
menschen hier auf der erde zu verbessern
und besser zu verstehen und falls ihr da
ein teil von werden wollt dann solltet
ihr euch unbedingt dieses video hier
ansehen da rede ich darüber wie man
astronaut oder astronauten bei der esa
werden kann und das ist übrigens auch
spannend für alle die sich aktuell noch
nicht bewerben können oder wollen und in
diesem sinne noch mal vielen dank an
alle die uns auf petri und supporten
danke an euch fürs zuschauen und wie
immer bleibt neugierig patrick